-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The 75th Annual Emmy Awards
and the Iowa caucuses
were held on Monday.
And in both cases,
the night's final award
went to an angry man
with terrible children.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden this week
traveled to Philadelphia,
as presidents typically do
after a horrific disaster.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today met
with congressional leadership
to discuss his request
for security funding,
which includes money
for border security --
'cause every day
this guy is looking more
and more like a flight risk.
[ Laughter ]
Vivek Ramaswamy
announced this week
that he was suspending
his presidential campaign.
He plans to return
to his true passion,
tearing down the teen rec center
to build a shopping mall.
[ Laughter ]
You can do it.
[ Chuckles ]
Former Arkansas Governor
Asa Hutchinson also announced
yesterday that he was suspending
his presidential campaign.
Did I say announced?
I meant muttered to himself.
[ Laughter ]
"What was that, Asa?"
[ Grumbles ]
"Aw, nothing.
[ Laughter ]
No, I wasn't talking to you."
"Are you still running
for president, Asa?"
[ Grumbles ]
"None of your business."
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview
with Fox News,
presidential candidate
Nikki Haley
said that the US has
"never been a racist country."
So if her campaign
doesn't pan out,
she could always get a job
teaching history in Florida.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Senator
John Fetterman
is reportedly working
on a memoir titled "Unfettered,"
and I like that
every picture of him
looks like he just thought
of that title.
[ Laughter ]
Pixar is reportedly planning
to lay off 20% of its workforce.
Oh, come on!
The man just lost his wife.
[ Laughter, "awws" ]
In 2009.
[ Laughter ]
Both a specious premise
and a huge bummer.
That's what Mike Scollins
brings to a monologue joke.
It doesn't quite track,
but everybody will be sad.
[ Laughter ]
A reptile wrangler in Australia
was recently called
after a mother
found a venomous snake
in her son's underwear drawer.
Said her son,
"Uh, she didn't find
anything else in there,
did she?
[ Laughter ]
Um, apropos of nothing,
does weed kill snakes?"
[ Laughter ]
The Michael Kors suit
worn by actress Nicole Kidman
in the AMC pre-movie ad
is set to go up for auction
and is expected to sell it
for up to -- for up to $10,000.
Or you could just use that money
to go to the movies
and get a snack.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Taco Bell has released
a new Cinnamon Twists cereal,
which hopefully sells better
than their last one,
Tac-o's.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!